so I have something extra special for
you today and I was wondering this
morning as I prepared for today's
program has everybody gone crazy has the
world lost its mind because not only is
Donald Trump talking about injecting
disinfectant you now have people like
dr. Phil and others comparing
coronavirus to things that have nothing
to do with coronavirus whatsoever and
aren't comparable in any characteristic
suicide deaths for example swimming-pool
deaths car accidents dr. Phil comparing
those two coronavirus how did things get
this crazy that was all put to shame
this weekend if you can imagine by Rudy
Giuliani who at one point was Donald
Trump's personal attorney is he still
working for Trump I have no idea I don't
know if Rudy knows I don't know if Trump
himself knows in any case Rudy Giuliani
was furious on Fox News with Laura
Ingraham furious why he says why all of
this commotion about testing and contact
tracing for coronavirus when we don't do
any contact tracing for obesity we don't
do any contact tracing for heart disease
we don't contact trace for cancer now
these are Rudy's words these are not my
words take a look and you will also
notice once again
Rudy looking very disheveled his eyes
half shut and his glasses crooked again
we never know what their explanation for
that is with Rudy Giuliani Michael
Bloomberg is going to handle the tracing
army of tracers in New York we learned
today there were six raids everybody for
cancer yeah our mayor treats everybody
for cancer and heart disease and and and
obesity and I mean a lot a lot a lot of
things kill you more than more than
covet 19 so he should be traced for all
those things well there are lives he
possesses a certain degree of risk we
should trace everybody for cancer and
heart disease and obesity and Laura
Ingraham just grins and nods along and
she has to know how stupid this is right
and I said it last week tell me that
Laura Ingraham is aware that this is all
garbage
contact tracing obesity hey this is
Sally from the CDC is this Eric Eric
listen one of your co-workers has tested
positive for being morbidly obese and we
are contact tracing oh don't worry we
bring our own lunches to work and mine
is far lower calorie than his contact
tracing obesity and cardiovascular
disease you can't go to work and cough
and give five coworkers congestive heart
failure
you can't sneeze on the subway and all
of a sudden half the subway car becomes
obese does Rudy know these conditions
aren't contagious what do people think
here and and I actually there's a more
serious question that is beyond just
Rudy Guiliani do you think that the
broader public is confused I'm being
serious now is the public confused about
communicable versus non communicable
disease like is part of what we're
seeing because a portion of the
population doesn't realize that not
every medical condition or disease is
contagious it I feel like an idiot
asking it but maybe we need to do a
survey that says rate the following in
terms of how contagious they are one to
ten and we say flu measles obesity a
broken bone a car accident like do do we
actually need to do that maybe we're all
laughing at Rudy and the problem is much
bigger than Rudy Giuliani and a whole
bunch of the population is thinking the
exact same thing because think about it
we wonder how could all these people be
so furious about the lockdowns who's out
there without a mask like maybe people
don't understand the difference between
communicable and non-communicable
disease I don't know the answer but I
would be curious to see what you think